Damien with something this sprawling and
ambitious I guess I'm curious where you
even start and what the gestation
process is like for a script like this I
mean how long are you researching it and
thinking about it and then what's the
spark that kind of gets you to actually
sit down and start writing it took about
yeah 12 years or so I remember of just
kind of the thing gestating at first
um
I it might have always been sort of a
you know fan of Hollywood history and
and old Hollywood but I think the first
thing that really sort of sparked this
as a project was
reading a certain kind of couple of
things about this era that just really
um sort of threw me for a loop that did
not feel like they comported to what I
had in my mind what I realized was sort
of a misconception in my mind of of the
early days of Hollywood when you sort of
dig into the into the muck a little bit
you know and you read for instance
reminiscences of sort of people who were
on the ground who haven't really you
know weren't really PR trained to kind
of tell their stories
um you would hear things about you know
about just the the sort of the the
turbulence of the time the the amount of
drugs floating through Los Angeles at
the time the the uh the kind of
recklessness with which movies were made
at least compared to today and and then
the sort of way in which a society that
allows that kind of uninhibited unhinged
Behavior the way that that made that
Society I would say especially prone to
being completely sort of bulldozed Away
by what otherwise might have seemed
almost a trivial technological change
just this idea of putting sound on you
know sync sound uh uh and marrying them
to pictures something that had been
tried in the early 20s it had been tried
in the mid-20s you know there were even
sound films in 26 but it wasn't until
you get to 27-28 where it just suddenly
takes off and I think it helped usher in
a whole set of new moral codes a new set
of kind of regulations a whole new
outlook on Hollywood that before that
had really been this kind of wild west
West Coast Outpost Outpost very separate
from Wall Street separate from the East
Coast separate from Broadway almost
antithetical and oppositional to those
things but once sound comes in once you
get to the late 20s you see this whole
sort of influx of East Coast money East
Coast Talent Broadway talent and a kind
of respectability starts to settle into
Hollywood that just again was very
antithetical to the sort of vulgar
tawdries you know one step from the
circus experience that I think the
earlier silence sort of exhibited so uh
yeah so it just sort of became this
bigger story I think than than I had
used to think it was and that made it
feel like fodder for a movie yeah well
Justin I was fascinated to hear that one
of your influences here was AC DC and I
was wondering if you talk a little bit
about uh what the kind of you know
reference points were for you for this
that were not 20s jazz
yeah we did talk about rock and roll a
lot um at the beginning we knew we were
going to use uh the lineup of a jazz
band with the brass section the Rhythm
Section at least for the on-screen stuff
and a lot of the score as well but we
didn't want to feel like 20s Jazz we
didn't want it to have that kind of
quaint gentle feel that so much of the
Jazz at least the Jazz that was recorded
back then we wanted a lot of riffs a lot
of really heavy driving riffs and so
many of the pieces are built on that
kind of strategy and then we would give
it to you Unison horns or Unison saxes
and it would give this real muscularity
to it that felt very different than 20s
Jazz so it was believable enough I think
because it was the lineup of a 20 span
so often but it was a lot more muscular
because it was built on that really like
heavy riff based style of writing Tom I
feel like you're using the music a lot
to tie everything together and give the
kind of unity to this crazy chaotic
sprawling thing I mean I you know I
think about the other movie you've done
with Damien and you know they're
ambitious movies but they're essentially
focusing on a couple of characters
usually here you've got a lot more and
I'm wondering for you what some of the
challenges were dealing with such a big
Ensemble and so many subplots and how
the music helped you kind of tie that
stuff together yeah I mean I I would say
that this this was
the most challenging movie I think we've
worked on together and it was probably
the hardest movie I've ever worked on
um you know you mentioned the other
movies Whiplash La La Land I mean those
were two-handers first man is kind of a
single character movie
um you know Damien always knew you know
that this was going to be an ensemble
you know the whole idea was to
show how people come to these people
come to Hollywood to be transformed they
come for a better life they come you
know they come to find a better version
of themselves and invariably they're
they're transformed the other thing
Damon was clear about is just that we
were gonna be making a maximalist
picture so the style was going to be
very overt uh out of the gate it was we
were just going to kind of throw in the
kitchen sink I mean it was just go For
Broke and but at the same time because I
think you know the storytelling Damien
would always talk about with me had to
do with contrast and so we might start
Max list but you know because of the
journey that these characters are taking
we may we would invariably end up in
different places so sometimes we end up
in a place where stylistically it's very
quiet or it's it's it's classically put
together
um such as the cement Gene Smart and and
and Brad Pitt but yeah I think I think
Justin's music which I had from the very
beginning I mean as soon as I got
dailies I already had rough demos of
Justin score that absolutely helped kind
of glue the chaos together and also you
know gave me something to follow in
terms of pace and Rhythm you know this
up-tempo coked up often coked up uh
energy was something that we could kind
of Bounce picture off of for every every
scene where picture where there was it
was set to music we we kind of repeated
this this process but it it made way for
what you see in the picture
uh well Mary I have to say I was
completely blown away by your work in
this movie by the costumes because I
feel like you know there's so many great
costumes this movie the characters are
always trying to you know they're trying
to convey who they want the world to
think they are through their clothes and
my favorite example of that is Eleanor
the Gene Smart character like and
watching a movie again tonight like I
just was blown away by every outfit she
has and I was wondering if you talk a
little bit about your conception of that
character and what you were trying to
say about her and what she's trying to
say about herself through what she's
wearing
um well first we had the good luck to
have to dress Jean Smart who was not
only statuesque and 510 which helped
carry some of the concepts for her
character but she was I mean the the
pitch for her was that she should be you
know when you first meet her in the
movie you recognize who she is amongst
many many other people at that party and
and it's you remember who she is and
then she continues that sort of of
outrageous
depiction of herself and it's just that
this is her she's wants to draw as much
attention to herself as all the people
that she's covering in her in her
writing so that was the idea is sort of
an eccentric approach and like I said
having Gene play the part was an extra
bonus now in terms of the look of the
movie I was wondering how you know what
Tom was saying about this being a
maximalist movie and it has such kind of
wildly varying tones and it's kind of a
more is more movie how does that inform
the approach to cinematography oh
well
um it's definitely you know the the
script on what Damian was looking for
and our discussions was
to not make it like a typically period
movie but rather uh our view or like a
modern view of of of that but um I think
the the general idea was to be
expressive you know and and for me it
felt also like you don't want to light
it like in an artificial way but rather
actually see how it looked back then for
real and go into that gritty reality of
the dirt and the sweat and the Heat and
the the sort of dingy parts of the world
and reality and and
um so we also with with the scope of the
film being like
um so big you wanted to be able to see
everything
um in a way like see see everything in a
big scope but still go into the details
and um
I think lighting wise it was a
naturalistic approach but um with the
sort of look of the film we looked for
something more expressive in a sort of
impressionistic way but like in a in an
expressive way so
um we we explored different ways of
treating the film stock and we push
processed the whole film to create
contrast and to see color better and to
um and the lighting is sort of
naturalistic right it's just that we
have um had also contrast the approach
to to things in order to help the
dynamic part of that
and and Flo I'm assuming that you know
the research on a movie like this for a
production designer must be a lot of fun
and also extremely uh arduous and and
thorough uh and I'm curious for you if
you know the way that Damien was talking
about how when he was doing his research
he kind of made these discoveries things
that surprised him
um what were some of your favorite
discoveries in the research process and
uh what surprised you about this era and
that found its way into the production
design
um well I really have to start with the
script I mean Damien wrote this amazing
world that the first read was really
inspiring for me because I just wanted
to jump into those visuals and the thing
that surprised me was in 1926 when our
story starts Los Angeles was in its
really early days of development and
they were just starting to do all the
urban planning and we quickly we found
this image of Beverly Hills in 1926 with
this big dirt road and the singular palm
tree and we really connected on the fact
that that was where we wanted the
environment and the visual story to
start and we looked to a lot of research
that ranged from the real depravity that
was happening in Los Angeles we found
those census photographs of the homeless
issues in the 1920s and then in contrast
all of uh this world that people were
building all the architecture that was
happening and all the influences that
ranged from
you know Spanish Revival Gothic Tudor
and Damian wanted the film to not feel
like we do on many period films that
it's not 1926 that it's inspired by
earlier periods or what's to come so
it's always like this constant process
of finding research and cobbling that
together and then creating like our own
expressionistic version of saying uh
what are these characters going through
what was really fun is tapping into like
the early prototypes of what the camera
boxes look like what the microphones
look like how that quickly developed so
even as we progress in those sets in the
sound era that they're developing and
changing and you know we'd really try to
build the world as they were doing it
and the access and the depravity and
show those contrasts throughout
now in terms of the excess you know Andy
uh watching that opening party sequence
yeah
watching that opening party sequence
today I was just thinking what a task
you had in terms of there's so much
cacophony and yet you and you give a
sense of the chaos and the cacophony and
yet you're still uh the dialogue is
still completely clear you hear
everything you're supposed to to hear I
mean what for you were the biggest
challenges on this movie
well uh that's a good question
um pretty much everything I think uh
that I mean coming on as kind of the
last
creative process in in the making of the
film when we do the sound mix it's kind
of an advantage in some ways because I'm
I can have the eyes and ears of an
audience in a sense because I haven't
had the Journey of making it up to that
point and getting used to things so I
can be the one to sit with Damien and
say I think we need to make this a
little clearer because I'm not fully
understanding something whereas
everybody else might be more familiar
because they've been living with it for
a while so uh for me working with the
music I mean it was it was incredible
because we had to create these Dynamics
huge Dynamics which I think were the
real punctuations of the film and the
turning points and the corners of the
film so it was um there were a lot of
challenges and and going into the
kinescope set for instance in silent
movies I mean the cacophony that was
created through all the dialogue the
sound effects all the different pieces
of music that you hear as you journey
through it's such a wonderful contrast
to then going to this first time they
shoot sound where it's dead silent and
every single little squeaker movement is
is carefully monitored and structured I
don't like the way the sound guy was
treated in that sequence but that's
another story
um
but no it was everything I mean there
was an incredible challenge but we we
had a lot of fun doing it and um yeah it
was great well I feel like we're just
getting started but we're already out of
time so thank you all so much for coming
and uh talking with me
thank you thanks for coming